wir machen jetzt endlich da ja ganz
viele von euch nach uhrzeit
klassischerweise verwendet man um
sauerkraut herzustellen ja den weißkohl
aber wir werden heute rotkohl nehmen
einfach weil das ein bisschen poppiger
ist weil das noch ein bisschen was
anderes ist diejenigen von euch die ein
klassisches sauerkraut herstellen wollen
können aber einfach den rotkohl den ich
jetzt hier verwende in dem video durch
weiß wohl austauschen und dann habt ihr
ein klassisches normales zell ist aber
trotz nur dass ihr euch nicht wundern
wenn ihr gleich mal eine alte küche
sieht und nicht mehr wie hier das rezept
ist aus der macht der ernte haltbar
challenge 2020 das ist eine video
challenge die ich jedem sommer
veranstaltet spiel gerade dabei die
challenge 2021 vorzubereiten und ich war
das total schade die alten rezepte
rauszuschmeißen deswegen dachte ich kann
ich das hier auf dem kanal noch mal mit
euch die challenge ist immer was mich
richtig drauf hin liefere das macht
jeden sommer für meine
newsletter-abonnenten wir alle zusammen
wenn die neue haltbar macht saison
starten können
erlebe ich euch ganz viele tipps und
rezepte mit an die hand und dann sind
wir gewappnet um unsere ganze diesen
ernte schwämme einzukaufen und zu
kommentieren einzulagern und so weiter
also freue ich mich super auch wenn ihr
mit dabei seit der liegt ist unten in
der video beschreibung ist es wie gesagt
völlig kostenlos du brauchst für dieses
rezept ein kilo rotkohl keinen april
eine große zwiebel einen esslöffel nicht
theoretisch salz 1 teelöffel
pfefferkörner zwei piment körner und
zwei gewürznelken ich würde dir sehr
dazu raten nur einwandfreies frisches
bio gemüse zu fermentieren weil
aufgespritzten gemüse oft gar keine
milchsäurebakterien mehr vorkommen und
oli gibt es auch keinen fermentation du
kannst zum fermentieren schraubgläser
oder einkocht lehrer verwenden das ist
ganz egal als erstes solltest du aber
dafür sorgen dass das zugehört möglichst
sauber und im besten fall sogar steril
ist es ist also erst mal eine runde
spielen angesagt danach stehe realisiere
ich mein gesamtes zubehör mit heißem
wasser alles gut abkühlen lassen
schließlich wollen wir die
milchsäurebakterien die auf dem gemüse
ja nicht grillen dann schaust du dir das
gemüse selbst an
das sollte möglichst frisch sein und auf
keinen fall schädlich oder vergammelt
jetzt legst du ein unbeschädigtes cool
bleibt beiseite das brauchen wir später
noch und treibt den rotkohl und den
apfel entweder mit einer küchenrolle
oder mit einem krauthobel je nachdem was
du da hast schneide ist die zwiebel in
kleine würfel und vermischt alles
zusammen mit den gewürzen und dem salz
in einer großen schüssel dann die ärmel
hochkrempeln jetzt wird es nämlich bunt
das rotkraut knet ist so nämlich jetzt
so lange durch bis flüssigkeit auf dem
gemüse austritt wenn du dir die hände
schmutzig machen willst kannst du dafür
auch einen holzstamm paar verwenden oder
du ziehst im handschuh an
jetzt gilt es das gemüse möglichst
kompakt und ohne lufteinschlüsse ins
glas zu füllen
dafür füllst du immer ein bis zwei
handvoll gemüse in das glas und stammt
ist es dann mit dem holz stampfer dem
kochlöffel oder mit der faust fest ein
ich bin für die gläser nur zu zwei
dritteln bei fermentiert das gemüse auf
brodelt und blubbert und es so weniger
wahrscheinlich ist dass selbst
überlaufen
das gemüse muss zu jedem zeitpunkt
komplett von saft bedeckt sein und damit
kein gemüse auftreiben kann text los am
besten mit dem col blatt ab musst du
eben zur seite gelegt hast darauf kannst
du deine kleine tasse oder ein
eierbecher stellen um das ganze zu
beschweren und bunter die flüssigkeit zu
drücken natürlich kannst du auch filmend
ihr glas gewichte verwenden aber weil
ich glaube dass die wenigsten von euch
diese gewichte zu hause haben hier die
improvisierte version damit die
fermentation in gang kommt muss das
gemüse jetzt erstmal bei
zimmertemperatur gelagert werden und
nach ein zwei tagen fest schon langsam
an zu kümmern
ich bin immer ganz erstaunt wie schnell
das geht je nach rezept steht das gemüse
jetzt zwei bis zehn tage im warmen
danach sei dass du deine vermengte
dunkel und kühl lagern zb im kühlschrank
einem ungeheizten raum oder einem kühlen
keller der eignet sich auch sehr gut zum
lagern solange das gemüse von der
flüssigkeit bedeckt ist kann nicht
schimmeln da kann also
nichts schief gehen jetzt ist aber ganz
wichtig dass man das regelmäßig checkt
und darauf achtet ob alles noch unter
der lage ist oder ob vielleicht ein
viertel auf getrieben ist gegen dann
schön schnell abschöpfen damit sich da
kein schimmel bilden kann wenn ihr
größeren mengen fermentieren wollte und
nicht nur so ein zwei gläschen wollen
eine super praktisch wenn man das stadt
im glas die ad hoc macht der ist jetzt
relativ groß es gibt auch etwas kleinere
der töpfe mal wieder ein bisschen
praktischer sind als die gläser die
haben ja nicht so einen randstein füllen
kann
und der sorgt dafür dass gase austreten
können das ist wie so ein ventil
eigentlich so eine schleife das heißt
die luft kann raus blubbern weil er ja
auch ganz viele gase entstehen beim
kommentieren
aber es können keine keime ins innere
eindringen dass es super praktisch
gerade wenn man große menge an selbst
und will man natürlich auch nicht dass
die schlacht wird ist natürlich der
klassiker unter den kommentierten
gemüsen aber wusstet ihr dass man so gut
wie jedes andere gemüse auch
fermentieren kann
sie lässt dennoch mit förmchen
cherrytomaten das rezept verlege ich
euch da drin ansonsten geht raus macht
die welt ein bisschen grüner und wir
sehen uns am samstag wieder und segen
für ein neues video tschüss